I'd love to get your help
defining a phrase just I suppose
explaining a phrase and then segueing
into conversation around mental models
and cognitive biases and so on so
ordinary moments determine your position
and your position determines your
results so what what is meant by that
line and what is meant by position so
the counterintuitive Insight that I had
about decision making from studying
Buffett and Munger and Peter Kaufman and
a host of other people who who've
influenced my thinking is that they
almost never find themselves out of
position and if you want to think of it
as position as your circumstances
they're never forced by circumstances
into doing something that they don't
want to do and often that means they
look like an idiot in the short term but
in the long term they win and if you
consider Buffett for example we've
talked about you know he closes down his
partnership during a bull market in the
60s cuz he doesn't know how to invest
anymore he's lost touch he can't find
what what worked for him he reopens it
later in terms of Berkshire Hathaway
Time Magazine I think it was 1999 he's
on the cover as being out of touch 2001
stock market
burst right now today I think as of last
quarter he's got $150 billion doar on
the balance sheet and so what he's
always doing is he he's everybody thinks
he's out of touch and he looks like an
idiot but he always wins because no
matter what the outcome is he wins if
the stock market goes up he wins if the
stock market crashes he wins because
he's put himself in a position where no
matter what happens he can take
advantage of circumstances rather than
having circumstances take advantage of
him and I think that that's a key
element we don't realize if you put
Warren Buffett in a bad position mhm
where all of his options are bad it
doesn't matter how smart he is it
doesn't matter how Warren Buffet he is
everybody looks like an idiot when
they're in a bad position and everybody
looks like a genius when they're in a
good position do you then create that
position by having a handful of
Commandments and I'm making these up I'm
not saying this is what Buffett does
because I haven't tracked him as closely
as you have but for instance I know
someone who's of a similar cut from a
similar cloth and he's like no short
positions no leverage d d and he has
four or five rules that he follows which
means he doesn't always
beat the S&P 500 let's say but he's very
rarely in a position where he has to
where he's a distressed
seller or is forced into a bad position
right so he is able to play a very long
game so I guess my uh please keep going
but I'm wondering how you consistently
create that type of position so let me
talk about it in terms of finance and
then apply it to something else that's
totally you would think it doesn't apply
to so in finance like you can think of
low debt you can think of saving money
you can think of always having dry
powder it doesn't matter if you have the
best idea in the world if you can't take
advantage of that idea you might as well
not have the idea you have to be in a
position to take advantage of the ideas
that you have and you have to be in a
position where somebody can't sort of
like call you in at the exact wrong
moment because that's really expensive
as everybody sort of learned during the
great financial crisis and has now
forgotten
we seem to relearn these lessons over
and over again but positioning applies
to so many other things that we don't
think about and you can think about it
basically as in your sleep right did you
work out are you healthy are you eating
well are you investing in your
relationship with your partner what
position am I in in the moment that I
get into a fight or argument or
disagreement with my my partner or my
spouse and we don't think about the
position we're in at that moment but if
you imagine that there's a patch of
grass between you and them is that grass
dry or is it wet have I watered that for
months in which case the spark isn't
going to light it on fire or is this
smallest little spark going to start
this forest fire and the position that
we bring into those arguments matters a
lot in terms of the quality of the
outcomes that we get and I'll give you
another example with we were talking
about kids earlier and I assume a lot of
people listening have kids mhm one of my
kids came home with an exam he got a
really terrible Mark and he hands it to
me he's like a teenager so he like hands
it to me he's like I did the best I
could walks away and normally the
conversation ends there and I was like
okay well now is not the moment that
we're going to talk about this because I
know got this teenage attitude thing
going on but we're going to circle back
to this and so later that night I was
like talk to me about what it means to
do the best you can and what he told me
about the best he could was like when he
sat down to write that test from 10 10
to 11 he focused all of his energy and
all of his effort on it he made the best
decisions possible from 10 to 11 but
what he forgot or didn't really
appreciate is what position was he in at
10:00 a.m. when he sat down to write
that test did he fight with his brother
in the morning yep he did did he eat a
healthy breakfast nope he didn't did he
get a good night's sleep nope he was up
late did he study no he sort of half
asked it and so what happened was he was
in a bad position at the moment he sat
down to write that test he was Ill
prepared to write the test but yes he
did the best he could in that moment and
so often we think about life in terms of
how do I do the best I can in this
particular moment rather than how do I
put myself in the best position and part
of that is like we're always predicting
we're we're predicting creatures and so
we're always trying to gauge what the
outcome is and maximize towards that
outcome I want to go all in on Tesla I
want to go all in on whatever cuz
because I want to maximize my return and
what we don't think about is like okay
well what is the cost of doing that what
if I'm wrong and how do I position
myself for multiple possible Futures
where what if my idea is not correct can
I still survive and can I thrive on that
and if you look back and you sort of
like look back at Carnegie and
Rockefeller and all these you know
historical people who built these great
businesses including Buffett they always
take advantage of a weakness in somebody
else's position position when their
position is strong who else would you
and I know you mentioned a few names but
outside of Buffett
Munger who else would you put on
your short list and not to make you pick
favorites I'm sure that you could give a
very long list but just off the cuff if
you had to pick five to 10 people let's
just say could be four but you know but
let's aim for five or or slightly more
people who you really respect as
incisive deliberate decision makers who
would make that list so we have a mutual
friend Nal
rant he would be up there Patrick
Collison would sort of be up there cat
Cole who works at athletic greens yeah
totally one of my favorite people she's
always one step ahead she's
amazing I think that there's very few
people who are well positioned in
everything like if you look at somebody
who's extremely good at one thing like
Buffet they that comes with extreme
weaknesses but you can you can have a a
list of exemplars in your head almost of
different people who are good at
different positions but you have to pick
what what direction you're
going and then what positions do you
need to be good at to be good in that
direction and so for me like I Circle
back to sort of like core things right
which people don't really think about
but they're they're core to everything
we do in terms of like health and
relationships and friendship and purpose
and Community am I working on something
that I want to be working on am I am I
moving closer to my destination and is
my destination the place I want to go
and I think those questions are stuff
that we don't really ask ourselves we're
always so focused on like how do we
accomplish the outcome we want rather
than what are the key elements to this
process that allow me to play for a long
time am I going in the right right
direction and I want to get to where I'm
going MH so I am going to come back to
just the the broad question of how to
incorporate thinking about cognitive
biases if I'm saying that correctly or
mental Andor mental models I'm not
really I guess those are different I'd
love to have you let's begin there how
would you distinguish or Define mental
models and then I'm going to go micro
and then we'll zoom out so a great way
to think about mental models is the
source of all bad decisions is blind
spots mental models allow you to see a
problem through a different lens you can
look at the problem
through you can adopt a different
Persona a great example of a mental
model is like how would Tim Ferris think
about this and then I adapt like what I
know about you and I try to see the
problem from your perspective and if I
can see the problem from your
perspective now I've I've done the one
thing that actually gets me out of
cognitive biases which is the source of
all cognitive biases are basically we
believe that we're part like that what
we see is all there is and we learned
about this sort of in physics right in
grade nine I think where you're standing
on this train and you're carrying this
ball and the train is moving at 60 M an
hour and how fast is the ball moving
well relative to you the ball's not
moving but if you're watching the train
go by the ball's moving at 60 mil an
hour and so the source of all of our
problems is that we only see that we're
this person on the train holding this
ball and we can't see that there's a
person outside who has a completely
different view into the exact same
situation that we see so we can mentally
use these tools to sort of
accommodate how we can look into the
world from a different person's eyes or
through a different lens be that biology
or through thinking or through I mean
the most useful ones tend to be like and
then what you know just asking yourself
that simple question I accomplish this
and then what then what happens
inversion right how do I avoid all these
negative outcomes that I don't want to
get and the stoics you've talked about
this in the past the stoics have been
doing this for a long time they call it
a
premortem I think that those are just
really helpful ways and what they're
really doing is they're just allowing us
to put a different lens onto the problem
and see it through a different light and
by seeing it through a Different Light
we slightly reduce our blind spots into
the problem yeah totally I
found some of I haven't read these in
decades so caveat Lector for anyone who
picks these up but some of Edward
debono's work I think he's originally
maltes but it's a debono's two words but
or actually he may just be a malt
citizen I can't I can't can't Peg the
nationality it doesn't really matter he
wrote a book called lateral thinking he
has another one I think it's called the
six thinking hats or something along
those lines which similarly very helpful
just for forcing yourself as a as a
portion of a practice to look at the
same situation with a different lens a
different set of questions a different
perspective